[Música]
si francia y su costura inspiran al
mundo entero la ciudad de lunes build es
en cierto modo su capital aquí se enseña
una técnica muy precisa una puntada de
menos de un milímetro que multiplicada a
lo largo de varias semanas da como
resultado esto
una pieza de bordado de una finura
incomparable
muy bien siguió así siempre de este lado
bueno
para realizarlo se utiliza un pequeño
gancho que lleve el nombre de la ciudad
se llama gancho o lunéville es un punto
de cadeneta que hacemos con nuestro
gancho de dulce pasamos el hilo por el
agujero cogemos el hilo por debajo lo
subimos por el pequeño bucle
y luego en hebras delicadamente el
siguiente agujero
y me lleva 20 años enseñando esta
técnica de aprendices de todo el mundo
como angela de moldavia que acaba de
empezar el segundo mes de su aprendizaje
y me siento muy orgullosa de esto a
primera vista parece que se ha hecho
rápidamente
pero son muchísimas horas de trabajo
cuántas horas
dos semanas
porque el bordado del une bill es más
que un pasatiempo a principios del siglo
20 era incluso el principal taller del
sector de la costura impulsado por los
pedidos del castillo del un event
[Música]
en el campo muchas bordadoras trabajan
en casa cuando el tiempo era bueno
trabajaban junto al aire libre los años
20 habían 25 mil personas trabajando
como bordadoras
un auge que se detuvo con la llegada de
las máquinas
esta máquina de bordar era un competidor
directo de la puntada lunéville ya que
los costos de producción eran mucho más
bajos
a la izquierda bordado hecho a mano a la
derecha bordado a máquina una imitación
menos refinada que casi acaba con la
puntada del une bien pero la bordadora
es tuvieron una idea revolucionaria
añadir abalorios y lentejuelas a sus
famosas puntadas
y aquí hay una parte en turista con
pequeños abalorios cocidos y aquí una
parte con pedrería lentejuelas y
abalorios
y la idea funcionó impulsó el punto de
lunéville en las pasarelas de los
desfiles de alta costura y en las de
pequeños diseñadores como christina no e
tras un curso de formación en el
castillo de long evil decidió lanzar su
propia marca de accesorios
utilizó la puntada lund y la para hacer
fondos y pequeños adornos y accesorios
cuya producción sigue siendo a muy
pequeña escala
estoy orgulloso de mantener viva la
puntada y de hacer cosas modernas con
una técnica antigua
y un saber hacer que ahora está
protegido desde su inscripción en la
lista del patrimonio cultural inmaterial
de la unesco
el rosado podría ser demasiado intenso
para el estado de ánimo que se necesita
la alta costura francesa también brilla
gracias a prestigiosas firmas como
hermes fundada en 1837 por un fabricante
de arneses ecuestres y sillas de montar
ahora es internacionalmente conocida por
sus pañuelos de seda cuadrados lanzados
un siglo después en 1937 su cd está a
pocos kilómetros de lyon y la producción
comienza con un diseño en acuarela que
luego se reelabora por ordenador
tengo que hacer muy precisa el objetivo
es que la diferencia entre el prototipo
del artista y la sede impresa se anula
así que mi trabajo es tanto artístico
como técnico porque adapto el diseño al
textil
no lo reproduzco trozos atrás lo adaptó
un poco para la sede empresa un trabajo
minucioso de 800 horas por pañuelo
a continuación comienza la mezcla de
colores con extrema precisión para
producir los tonos deseados
hacemos un primer control de conformidad
con diferentes pinceladas así si no está
bien
podemos arreglarlo después
a continuación viene la llamada
impresión al estilo del yo
cuadrado tras cuadrado los robots
apliquen los tintes siendo el más claro
el más oscuro
el último paso es el dobladillo una
costura a mano que requiere una
formación especial
algunas de nosotras nunca habían cosido
a mano
así que sentimos mucha presión cuando
empezamos
luego uno se tranquiliza y queda
totalmente encantado
es muy agradable trabajar con un
material tan bonito
los cuadrados de seda de hermes son
verdaderamente hermosos
creo que eso nos da una motivación extra
este dobladillo a la francesa es el
fruto de casi 100 años de perfección
un saber hacer poco común que la marca
ha querido reapropiarse
trasladando esta parte de su actividad a
la región del yo en 2012
[Música]